being black isn't a get out of jail card
ask candace owens
ask larry elder ask thomas sowell these
people are
you know uh shelby steele those people
are not
they're persona non grata on on
university
as condoleezza rice who wasn't allowed
to speak i think at wesleyan oh yeah
um concert pianist smart woman
but you're not on that side so those
people are afraid
they're afraid of true scholarship
of nuance and of of deep thinking
i think it was another guy was maybe
vaclav schmel i can't remember what
he said most of these people who are
driving this
debate who are coming up with these
terms like white privilege
like systematic racism and stuff like
that um
are at the bottom of a well and they're
looking up at their sliver of the sky
and all they can see is that sliver of
the sky
there isn't a comprehensive
understanding of the world when you live
in the real world and you have to make a
restaurant work when you have to manage
a restaurant
when you get down to the level of detail
nobody is talking about
your gender or your sex we got to get
the food to the customers man
and we got to stay in business which
means i don't have time for that i have
time for bottom line stuff
and then i got my kids and i got i got
to make my relationship work and i got
up
and i got this pain here so i'm nervous
about that
that's what it is to be a human being
yeah so a lot of this stuff when you say
getting in trouble
for what you said it's not real there's
a lot of chatter and a lot of white
noise yeah but you can ignore it your
job is to
just stay honest and and and be in the
business of original self-expression
and keep doing it because it's needed
and it's wanted bill burr will say that
billboard will be like he says crazy
things on stage and people are like
oh i mean i've seen people go are you
allowed to do you don't say that
and i say to be like oh you're so gutsy
i mean he goes no i'm not
eight people on twitter hate me
everybody else gets it and he's right
right they'll call him racist and then
it's like yeah but it's such a breath my
wife happens to be black
right not that that proves that anything
that's not a get out of jail
and it's not anymore being black isn't a
get out of jail card ask candace owens
ask larry elder ask thomas sowell these
people are you know uh
uh shelby steele those people are not
they're persona non grata
on on on university ask condoleezza rice
who wasn't allowed to speak i think at
wesleyan oh yeah concert pianist smart
woman
but you're not on that side so those
people are afraid
they're afraid of true scholarship
of nuance and of of deep thinking
and it requires that what about the
regular people though not the comics
that are supposed to be doing this and
the artists that are supposed to be
expressing themselves because that's
that's the big one i get now like the
amount of
mail i get every day from people that
are just like i have to be anonymous on
twitter
i can't post on facebook anymore all of
that stuff
because their job is not expression and
they're afraid they're going to lose
their job
if they they can yeah and that's what's
so disheartening is that
corporations if you work for a large
corporation they don't care they're
about their bottom line
you really think and it's not that
they're racist or anything
do you really think that uh because
adidas or nike or netflix or whoever
stands
uh against racism do you stand against
racism do
do you that's awesome i don't know if
you could go back and stop slavery would
you
wow you're so noble and thanks for
posting that
black square because that's what a
single mom in the hood
needs from you boy she must be breathing
a breath of fresh air
and she's trying to raise three kids
that must be fantastic and her other
kids
just got picked up on a marijuana bid
and is looking at getting
stuck in the system that he can't get
out but thanks for your black square
and thank you hollywood actors for
taking responsibility i appreciate that
because you guys are making such a
difference
it's embarrassing it's embarrassing and
thank you thank you for repeating the
phrase that was given to you
by someone you don't know like
systematic racism
and white privilege it sounds good it
makes you feel emotionally
cathartic i suppose what are you
actually doing
where were you when a hundred black
people were shot
in chicago over father's day weekend
five of them children who were killed
where were you
why are you not in the street there my
friends but you're not
because you're too busy because at the
end of the day you can't be
unfortunately sometimes things are
bigger than you are and so all you can
do is
is reach out like a [ __ ] and kind of
say i
let me tweet something i'm against
racism i'm
for peace and harmony you're for peace
and harmony i'm for war and chaos
dude i can't believe that but your
bumper sticker and that thing you put up
in your store really has changed my mind
so i i i just see a bunch of um it's
like
watching a bunch of people on on
stationary bicycles trying to get
somewhere and i it's
it's embarrassing there's a guy that's
about five houses over i will walk out
with you after this and show you who's
got the bernie bumper sticker
and you know co-exist and the whole
thing and he has literally the biggest
fence in the neighborhood
the biggest not only does he have a
fence in front of his house his door has
a fence in front of it i've never even
seen this before i'm sure they have more
of them in beverly hills
but like a you know his front door extra
fence right there and it's like oh well
you got all the bumper stickers right
right suddenly you like fences look i've
never been a fan of donald trump i don't
like his personality i don't think he's
an effective leader i have a lot of
criticisms i did not vote for him
um i'm not a fan never have been did you
vote for hillary i i did vote for
hillary and i don't like hillary
i i i didn't know what to do i couldn't
vote for that guy yeah i just
he he just uh and and especially in the
beginning when
he was like you know if if i have i want
to ban on muslims
i want to build a wall it just all
sounded un-american
but my biggest criticism of trump is
that he's he's a trumpist
yeah i mean you know if i were debating
trump i'd be like you care about trump
you don't care about the country so i i
have my my criticisms
but what's interesting about the sort of
and i was a critic of the i don't like
the idea of building a wall there's got
to be a smarter way to do this
i mean you know i just it just ugh it
just sounded terrible
so but but what's interesting about the
most vocal
the people that are really against the
wall
and things is the people that are doing
that live behind very expensive walls
try getting in
try getting over the wall that is
harvard the wall that is
yale the wall that is princeton the wall
that is wesleyan the wall that is
uh williams college house well forget
that
forget that isn't she responsible for
the tenderloin and uh isn't that her
district in in uh or is that maxine
waters the late mexican i'm not sure oh
vaccine is here yeah yeah
yeah so i mean of course so you people
live behind very expensive walls i can't
afford those walls
and i don't have the grades so but why
is it people can't connect those two
things well here's another thing
that i thought of that i thought kansas
owens was had said in
because what i've been doing lately is
i'm on youtube and i watch debates
between black conservatives and black
liberals
and i get a lot from both sides yeah i
love it i'm not
i'm not you know it's it's very
interesting i'm i'm the guy who's been
my dad had me reading thomas solo a long
time ago you know this stuff
but but what's what's uh interesting is
that
she said look if if black lives really
matter and you
you are worried about black the black
sort of uh
vote and the black you know political
influence which is what it comes down to
especially in local politics
you better get serious about
criminalizing the border
because if you have unchecked
immigration from south of the border
the latino vote god bless them is going
to
render your vote as an african-american
obsolete
you can say whatever you want but when
it comes down to
getting votes politicians are going to
be able to
skip over your districts it's not going
to matter
in five years and i i kind of i went ooh
wow oh that's a that's a contradict
that's a real that that puts the left in
in a real predicament here it really
does
because now you've got to get very
serious about uh immigration
maybe even draconian hard terrible
terrible problem when you have children
and you have desperate people trying to
come over your border
i don't know the answer i don't know how
to solve that but what a dilemma
and what a corner they have painted
themselves in if you're looking for more
honest and thoughtful conversations
about comedy instead of the non-stop
yelling you get everywhere else check
out our comedy playlist and if you want
to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're both
right over here and to get notified of
all future videos be sure to subscribe
and click the notification bell